[موسيقى]
دار الاوبرا السلطانيه تحفه معماريه
تحتضنها العاصمه العمانيه مسقط مبناها
يتكون من ثمانيه طوابق منها ثلاثه تقع تحت
الارض وخمسه فوقها يتناغم تصميمها
المعماري مع التراث العماني والعربي
والاسلامي في عهود مختلفه وتقعوا على
مساحه تتجاوزوا 80,000 متر مربع
[موسيقى]
على هذا المسرح الذي يتسعوا لاكثر من الف
شخص عزف وتغني اشهر الفنانين العالميين
والعرب ابرزهم فنان العرب محمد عبده
القيصر كاظم الساهر امال ماهر وغيرهم
الكثير ومع احتفال دار الاوبرا السلطانيه
بمرور عشر سنوات على افتتاحها ينتظر
الجمهور في السلطنه باقه من العروض
والحفلات خلال الفتره
[موسيقى]
دار الاوبرا السلطانيه تضم اكثر من 50
محلا تجاريا ما بين مقاهي ومطاعم
ومتاجر تتنوعوا انشطتها ومجالاتها لي
تشكيله الزائر
[موسيقى]
والمجوهرات وغيرها من ابرز مبيعات محل
الاوبرا جاليريا الذي ياتي على شكل رواق
يداخم مبنى دار الاوبرا السلطانيه
حلوه انه فيك يكون اوقات عندك ميتينك بدك
تاكل وبعدين ترجع تروح على الاوبرا تعمل
شيء هيك انترتين حسب اذا في اشياء احداث
حلوه تحضرها حسب انت ذوقك يعني
المتاجر بجانب الاوبرا جيدا من المناسب ان
تتناول وجبات الطعام او التسوق قبل الذهاب
الى الابيض
وانصح دائما السياحه بزيارتي هذا المكان
المطاعم والمقاهم هنا تعكس ثقافه وتاريخ
السلطنه يجب على اي شخص
ان ياتي الى الاوبرا السلطانيه
مبنى دار الاوبرا السلطانيه يعتبر من
المباني متعدده الاستخدامات حيث يمكنه ان
يستضيف فعاليات مختلفه كحفلات الاوبرا
والحفلات الموسيقيه والمسرحيه الى جانب
المؤتمرات والعديدي من الملتقيات الثقافيه
والفنيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي من العاصمه
العمانيه مسقط العربيه
[موسيقى]